for the marlins they will hand them all
off to sandy alcantara his 14th start
this season 59th in his career coming
off eight innings in a win against the
pirates on a day in which the marlins
absolutely needed him to be the ace
on the run and they got it
head first slide acuna tagged out on the
back of the helmet he didn't like that
very much
and alfaro with a perfect throw erases
acuna for out number one see if the
braves challenge this
they are look at the left hand
so acuna
got tagged in the back of the helmet and
then
slid into chisholm's knee
as he was rung up and called out but the
braves are going to challenge this call
at second and i think acuna beat it from
our vantage point looked like he got the
oven mitt in before chisholm smacked him
on the back of the helmet so the verdict
is in and he is safe
so acuna is at second base with his 12th
stolen base the call is overturned
swinging a shot to right field as he
comes through the braves take the lead
albie's around first steal
put on the brakes and albies continues
his red-hot hitting he's got 38 rbis and
the braves cash in a lead off walk and
lead one nothing two and two marlins
have three on the left side of the
infield against riley who swings and
misses and sandy has his first strikeout
tonight
charlie 4 starts on the road this year
1-1 with a 3-4-7 been good against the
marlins in his career as well
ground ball grapes had the shift on
swanson gets to it but has no play the
marlins will have him loaded
swung the infield around to the right
side
and it they've had some spin at the end
of the day marlins haven't loaded well
this could get interesting real fast
because adam duvall was seven for 14
against the braves sends this one out
toward right center field going back to
zukunu jr he reaches up and makes the
catch it will be deep enough to score
the game tying run and the marlins have
tied it here in the first inning
anguillard third dickerson at first the
2-2 pitch
he is swung on and missed and that will
take care of diaz and the marlins miami
ties the game one a piece we go to the
second slider's a developing pitch he's
been using it a little bit more of late
change up is a huge one of course you've
got 99 to fall back on all right listen
you like strikeouts he did that too his
last time out he had five from the fifth
inning on
adds to the degree of difficulty in this
day and age in baseball o2 count for
jorge alfaro
and morton carves him up alfaro turns
and grumbles he'll want those pitches
for alcantara
and charlie has back-to-back strikeouts
this one starts the second inning you're
pounding a guy in like that you throw
one on the black it probably looks like
it's 10 inches off the plate
after you're so conscious in swing and a
shot hit toward the left field corner
that's a base hit acuna around first on
his way to second he's digging hard
around two and he'll stop there
so acuna with a ringing double that's a
one out two base hit his 11th of the
year we're so used to seeing his numbers
so much higher even against the marlins
throughout his career he's got
tremendous numbers for ops over 900
shallow left long run in dickerson he's
going to get there with the sliding
catch what manager wouldn't love to see
a sliding two-hand catch from their
outfielder always using two hands
now corey got into position
did just as i said right nice sliding
catch but uses two hands to secure the
catch hello
pop-up slide to get into the throwing
position keep it
at second base
no balls in a strike from al contra for
the brave second baseman and he golfs
that ball toward the gap right center
field martay can't get it that'll score
ronald lacuna junior wave him home
ronald
ozzy albee's is in safely at second he's
got a single and a double and he's got
the braves in front again
32 starts that's a lot right but that
too can add to what our a little bit
outer character numbers on his breaking
ball in terms of average and hard hit
and all that
oh what a play by reilly the man in the
shift
and in play just tall enough dickerson
is
foiled by austin reilly and the marlins
are out one two three in the third
charlie preserves a 2-1 atlanta lead all
right one out for william contreras the
catcher who struck out his first time
this the younger brother
of the cubs catcher wilson contreras
jazz backhand jump throw to first
got him what a play jazz chisholm jr
looked like another number two on that
play
now ranging into the hole to the
backhand
and the jump throw in plenty of time
i'll tell you what jazz
shows us his athleticism
every way you can think of on a baseball
field we've seen it on the bases we've
seen it with the bat and we've seen it
with the glove
at a 22 pitch third inning as he fires
called strike three
and an 11 pitch fourth he needed that
he's had the two bounce back innings
after 21 pitch first and 11 pitch second
now
gets hit by the pitch again
he's been a target the last week or so
it's almost the same place every time
the the left tricep two-seam fastball
just boring in marlins have the tying
run in scoring position go ahead run it
first with one out in the last of the
fourth
line drive over swanson into left field
here comes isan diaz throw from left is
off the mark and john bertie has tied
the game at two
jazz left side base it
in comes alfaro bertie around third
throws off the mark jazz to second on
two rbi base hit for jazz chisholm
junior
marlins in front four to two
now starling martay who takes a strike
there's a look down to second
well
that's not good
jazz hobbled back to second base
you know that he's had issues with the
ankle donnie's out as well he's had
issues with the ankle and the hit by
pitch in iceberg
yeah the right ankle just collapsed as
he hit you know the pivot you know you
kind of hit in rhythm in motion as you
make your move towards third base
looks like he's staying in the game for
now and that's a good thing but we'll
keep an eye on it alfaro grabbing his
gear
after the hit by pitch heading down the
tunnel alfaro leaves the ball game if we
get any word on that again we hope that
it's more precautionary than anything
else
that's in there for a called strike
three
expecting something other than the
change-up perhaps five k's through five
for sandy marlins in front by two
and riley can't hold up would have been
a strike anyway
strikeout number six for sandy alcantara
went away in the sixth william contreras
sends this one out toward left center
field dickerson ranging over and he
makes another terrific sliding catch
great play by dickerson in left center
field robbing contreras of extra bases
and keeping the braves off the board
again in the sixth and now he's got to
face acuna who's had a big night two
runs a double a walk of steal
and a bullet hit inside the line fair
into the left field corner
adrianza on his way to third ron
washington's waving him around here he
comes relay throw won't be made and just
like that the braves are down to run
second double for ronald lacuna jr who's
up to 39 rbis marlons took three out of
four from the braves in atlanta trying
to get the first one of this three-game
set here tonight tying running second go
ahead run at first of all the two
strikes garcia deals and he strikes him
out it's a marlins win